INTENTIONALLY DROVE DIRECTLY
TOWARDS TROOPER MAY, AND
STRUCK HIM WITH THE STOLEN
VEHICLE."
((DENISE VALDEZ))
THE DETAILS ARE HARD TO HEAR,
BUT TONIGHT WE UNDERSTAND MORE
ABOUT THE INCIDENT THAT KILLED
AN NHP TROOPER.
((DENISE VALDEZ))
GOOD EVENING--- THANKS FOR
JOINING US AT FIVE...
I'M DENISE VALDEZ.
((CHRISTIAN CAZARES))
AND I'M CHRISTIAN CAZARES WE'RE
GETTING A CLOSER LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED DURING LAST WEEK'S CAR
CHASE TURNED SHOOTING ON THE
I-15.
FROM METRO HEADQUARTERS WITH THE
DETAILS.
ORKO?
((ORKO MANNA))
CHRISTIAN AND DENISE...
OUR COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO FEEL
THE LOSS OF N-H-P TROOPER MICAH
MAY.
HE WAS KILLED DURING A PURSUIT
ON THE I-15 LAST TUESDAY -- AND
WE'RE GETTING OUR FIRST LOOK
AT POLICE FOOTAGE FROM THAT DAY.
NEWLY-RELEASED AERIAL FOOTAGE
SHOWS PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS
CHASING A CARJACKING
SUSPECT, DOUGLAS CLAIBORNE...
AS HE DROVE ERRATICALLY ON
THE I-15 AND ALSO ON SURROUNDING
STREETS.
POLICE SAY CLAIBORNE STOLE
SOMEONE'S CAR...
AND EVEN USED A FOOT-LONG KNIFE
TO THERATEN THAT PERSON.
PAROLE AND PROBATION
OFFICERS NOTICED THE STOLEN
VEHICLE...
AND N-H-P TROOPERS HELPED WITH
THE PURSUIT.
WE'RE TOLD N-H-P TRIED TO USE
STOP STICKS SEVERAL TIMES...
INCLUDING WHEN TROOPER MAY LAID
THEM DOWN.
POLICE SAY CLAIBORNE
INTENTIONALLY HIT TROOPER MAY.
N-H-P WAS ABLE TO RAM THE
VEHICLE AND STOP CLAIBORNE.
THEN...
A HANDFUL OF OFFICERS OPENED
FIRE.
((
"OFFICERS
OBSERVEDCLAIBORNE GRABBING
TROOPER MAY'S GUN.
HE WAS STRUCK SEVERAL TIMES AND
SUBSEQUENTLY PRONOUNCED DEAD AT
THE SCENE." ))
((ORKO MANNA))
A METRO HELICOPTER THEN
ARRIVED ON THE I-15 TO TRANSPORT
TROOPER MAY TO U-M-C.
UNFORTUNATELY...
TROOPER MAY PASSED AWAY TWO DAYS
LATER, LAST THURSDAY.
((ORKO MANNA))
THERE WILL BE A VIGIL
TOMORROW NIGHT TO HONOR TROOPER
MAY.
IT WILL BE AT POLICE MEMORIAL
PARK -- AND EVERYONE IS INVITED
TO ATTEND.
REPORTING LIVE FROM METRO
HEADQUARTERS...
ORKO MANNA...
8 NEWS NOW.///